[Musique]
c'est ici à la boulangerie du château de
saint-germain-en-laye que se trouve la
meilleure galette aux amandes des
yvelines édition 2022 elle est préparée
de bon matin par sébastien briller
j'ai fait quatre galettes et il fallait
les quatre galettes soit vraiment
l'identique mon avis j'ai vu d'autres
galette et je pense que c'est vraiment
la régularité j'avais une galette qui
était vraiment très très assez élevé
mais en même temps très plate et pas
bomber la galette qui fait 30 cm et la
taille requis pour le concours toutes
façons un premier prix décerné pour une
galette travailler avec précision il
faut être hyper minutieux et faut
surtout pas trop tranché le feuilletage
après la cuisson avec le développement
du feuilletage et ben on voit apparaître
le décor il ya même des gens qui
demandent des galettes les parfums qu'on
n'a pas forcément mais c'est pas un
problème parce que là bas c'est toujours
à peu près la même une crème d'amande
d'un feuilletage ce qui compte c'est la
régularité un maximum de régularité le
site en un qui est gros et petit bain
après c'est parti pour à peu près une
heure de cuisson à 170° ça va nous
permettre aussi vous faire découvrir un
petit peu plus
vendre sûrement beaucoup de galettes
sébastien a d'ailleurs remporté le
deuxième prix du meilleur salariés de
récompenses symboliques pour le gérant
michael fourché ça prouve que on est
dans le vrai on est on est vraiment dans
le sang pour sang fait maison c'est qui
est très important pour moi les gens
sont sensibles je pense aujourd'hui
à ce genre de concours aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas on s'approprie un peu le
boulanger on va chez mon boulanger et
c'est une fierté pour moi et pour tous
mes clients la boulangerie est qualifié
pour le concours régional qu'elle
connaît déjà puisque son croissant avait
terminé 2e d'ile-de-france de galettes
seront envoyés pour être jugé entre le 4
et le 7 janvier